better to slow sharply over the first
half of the forecast period
that predominantly reflects the
significant adverse impact of the sharp
rises in global energy and tradable
goods prices on most uk households real
incomes
it is a measure of the scale of the
shock
that total real household disposal
income is projected to fall by one and
three quarter percent in this 2022 which
apart from 2011 would be the largest
contraction since comparable records
began in 1964.
and i must say that i recognize the
hardship this will cause for many people
in the uk
particularly those on the lowest incomes
often with little or no savings
who are hit hardest by increases in the
prices of basic necessities like food
and energy
as a result of the associated decline in
activity
although the unemployment rate is likely
to fall further in the near term
to 3.6 in q2
it is projected to rise to five and a
half percent in three years time given
the sharp slowdown in activity
with monetary policy acting to ensure
that longer-term inflation expectations
are anchored at the 2 targets
upward pressure on cpi inflation is
therefore expected to dissipate over
time
global commodity prices are assumed to
be consistent with the conditioning
parts for energy prices and so rise no
further in the central projection
global bottlenecks are expected to ease
over time
and the weakening and growth and
building excess supply leads domestic
inflationary pressures to subside
once cpi inflation starts to fall it is
projected to fall relatively quickly
to a little above the two percent target
in two years time
largely reflecting the waning influence
of external factors
and to 1.3 in three years
well below the target and mainly
reflecting weaker domestic pressures
the risks to the inflation projection
are judged to be skewed to the upside at
these points
given the risks of more persistent
strength in nominal wage growth and
domestic price setting than we have
assumed
i'll now turn to the monetary policy
decision
the npc's remit is clear
that the inflation target applies at all
times
reflecting the primacy of price
stability in the uk monetary policy
framework
the framework also recognizes that there
will be occasions when inflation will
depart from the target as a result of
shocks and disturbances
the economy has recently been subject to
a succession of very large shocks
russia's invasion of ukraine is another
such shock
in particular
should the current very elevated levels
of global energy and tradable goods
prices prove persistence
this will necessarily weigh further on
most uk households real incomes and many
uk companies profit margins
this is something monetary policy is
unable to prevent
but what monetary policy can do is to
ensure that as this really economic
adjustment occurs
it does so in a manner consistent with
achieving the two percent inflation
target sustainably in the medium term
while minimizing undesirable volatility
and output
recent developments have exacerbated
materially both the near-term peak in
cpi inflation and the prospective
negative impact on activity and
medium-term inflationary pressures
nevertheless given the current tightness
of the labour market continuing signs of
robust domestic cost and price pressures
and the risk that those pressures will
persist the committee voted at this
meeting to increase bank rate
by a further 0.25 percentage points
to 1
based on their updated assessment of the
economic outlook most members of the
committee judge that some degree of
further tightening in monetary policy
might still be appropriate in the coming
months
there are risks on both sides of that
judgment and a range of views among
these members on the balance of risks
the mpc will continue to review
developments in the light of incoming
data and their implications for
medium-term inflation
given the uncertainty around the outlook
it is unsurprising that there were a
range of views amongst members of the
committee about the extent of tightening
required at this meeting and in the
coming months
this reflects the narrow path we're
navigating given the magnitude of the
risks on both sides of our inflation
projections
reflecting the risks on one side of that
narrow path at this meeting three
members preferred a 0.5 percentage point
increase in bank rate
reflecting the risks on the other side
however there were also a range of views
about the need for
an extent of any further tightening and
policy in the coming months
while most members judge that some
degree of further tiny might still be
appropriate some members judge that the
risks around activity and inflation over
the policy horizon were more evenly
balanced and that such guidance was not
appropriate at this juncture
finally the mpc is providing further
information
on unwinding the stock of assets
previously purchased as part of the qe
programmes
as bank rate is being increased to one
percent
and consistent with the mpc's previous
guidance
the committee will now consider
beginning the process of selling uk
government bonds held in the asset
purchase facility
the committee recognizes the benefits of
providing market participants with
clarity on the framework for any
potential sales programme
the npc is therefore asked bank staff to
work on a strategy for uk government
bond sales and will provide an update at
our august meeting
this will allow the committee to make a
decision at a subsequent meeting on
whether to commence sales
i should reiterate that no decision on
whether to commence sales has yet been
made
the committee reaffirmed that that
decision will depend on economic
circumstances including market
conditions at the time
and the sales would be expected to be
conducted in a gradual and predictable
manner so as not to disrupt the
functioning of financial markets
thank you ben dave and i will be happy
to take your questions now
thanks very much andrew um as always
please wait for the microphone to get to
you and also if you could identify
yourselves and your media organization
go to faisal first and then um i think
ed please
thanks governor faisal islam bbc um this
appears to be uh very close to a
recession i don't know how you define it
how can you justify to
households hit by this cost of living
crisis um further exacerbating that
in the middle of what looks very much
like a recession
well thanks as you say it is a very weak
uh projection it's a very sharp slowdown
there's a technical definition of a
recession it doesn't meet that but put
that to one side it is a very obviously
sharp down in activity
so turn into the question i mean it's a
very good question about why therefore
should we uh increase uh bank rate at
this point in time and i've come back to
this analogy that i used and have used
recently of this narrow path and the
challenge of course is that on the other
side of the path is is is where
inflation currently is
but more particularly the risks as we as
we see them going forwards and i would
highlight as as we say in the
um in the minutes actually in statements
that the risks are if anything on the
upside we think to inflation
going forwards and that comes i think i
would highlight two things one and
pointed to it that we have a very tight
labor market
so yeah we have
unemployment currently at 3.8 we think
it will actually go down somewhat of
course it's interesting looking back i
think over the last uh two years or so
as to
um how much we now know and i would
emphasize now no because there was huge
uncertainty through the covert period on
this question and it's a very very
important question but of course the
unemployment path has been very
different
um
and the labor market is very tight i
mean i you know i spend a lot of time
going around the country talking to
businesses
i'm sure you do as well and and frankly
you know the first second and third
thing they want to talk about quite
reasonably is is the tightness of the
labor market the challenges they're
having
uh in recruitment and what that means
for uh for pay
the second thing is i would highlight on
this risks point is that one of the
things we've highlighted before is that
covid the covid period did lead to quite
a substantial buildup in unexpected
saving in the economy so the question of
course continues is it and under this
new like setting of the state of the
economy is how exactly are those savings
going to be
used and are they going to be used to
sort of you like buffer
demand but of course that then we have
to look at that from the point of view
of the risks to inflation so the point
being is we are walking this yeah this
very narrow path now
and and to your question i mean the
reason for the approximate reason for
the you know for raising bank rate at
this point is
not only i mean it's not it's not only
the current profile of inflation what is
to come and of course what that could
mean for inflation expectations
but the risks as well and i would
particularly emphasize the risks than it
would be
um
no i think that summarizes it well in a
very difficult position reflecting the
nature and the scale of the shocks we're
facing and as the governor said in his
opening remarks
the effects of those on real incomes are
unavoidable unfortunately
they're externally driven and not
something that monetary policy is really
in a position to offset and it really is
important i think to keep in mind
their enormous scale
the governor gave a figure for the
estimated or predicted
increase in the off-camera energy cap
this year
an estimate based on where the forward
market is at the moment
of i think around 1500 pounds
per household very significant that
comes off on top of what was i think
something like 250 or 300 pounds rise
last year
if you include
the rises driven by a mixture of the
pandemic and the russian invasion in
prices of other
imported goods traded goods
you can probably more than double that
increase in energy over that two-year
period
so we're talking about a very
significant hit to incomes
the rise in mortgage costs
as a result of rising interest rates is
a fraction of that number
um
and then precisely to mine both are
estimates but i'd be surprised if it was
much more than one-tenth
the rise
so that's the unfortunate position we're
in this this cost of living crisis the
hit to incomes
is unavoidable
the judgment the committee is having to
make is as andrew said between
the two-sided effects of this hit
on the one hand high inflation now
could persist for longer if it gets more
embedded in domestic
prices
on the other hand
significant
hit to incomes and thereby spending and
domestic demand
will
push down on inflation over the medium
term and those are the two things we're
trying to balance
ed
thank you um ed conway from sky news
governor um it's really just to kind of
follow on from from that point
would you say that you know this pain
that we that households will be facing
over the next 12 months 24 months
in higher inflation
fall in that standard of living
effectively is that
is that necessary is that the only way
of getting inflation down is that the
medicine we need to take is that what
you're suggesting
well i think the first thing to say ed
and this is
really the big difference in a way
between
you know the the as i explained in sort
of the
drew the sort of contrast between the
us the euro and the uk
the biggest driver downwards of
inflation is is the shock to real income
this is the point ben's just made really
which is it's it's not monetary policy
it's it's the shock to real income
which as i said is the
barring one year is the largest since
records began
and that is why um you know we've been
quite careful therefore about
calibrating
what the
unless what the appropriate response of
monetary policy should be to us
i mean i would note that as you can see
in the monetary policy report that the
profile uh that we published for
unconstant interest rates on the
previous heading does not did not
on the previous setting it would not
bring inflation back to target um
and obviously we looked at that a lot as
we tend to do during the during the
process but i would emphasize this point
that in terms of pain i'm afraid ben has
made the point very very well the
biggest in a sense
driver is the real income shock which is
coming from the change in the terms of
trade
coming particularly as we've said from
energy prices
uh and and also now
also from some core goods and some food
uh food sources
yeah in respect to that therefore i
don't think it's right to say it's
the medicine it is its own medicine
the shock that is pushing up let's uh
come out at that press conference uh now
just quickly mention as well the market
reaction to uh the bank of england uh
statement uh and press conference the
british pounds down 1.8 percent as we
stand uh against the u.s dollar today in
reaction to this uh negative outlook for
uh lower growth and higher inflation
simon french chief economist at uh
pamela gordon able to join me now to add
his reaction
and and clearly simon this is this is
not an optimistic outlook that we've
gotten from the bank of england today
but are there some factors that their
outlook is based on that might not
materialize and therefore things might
not be as bad as they're predicting
right now yeah well one of the reasons
why sterling is so weak and you showed
the data on the screen for your viewers
is that the market had been ahead of
this announcement expecting
this to be the first interest rate
increase of a further
six or seven this year now i think what
we saw in both the commentary from the
governor of the bank of england and
indeed in the monetary policy report is
that is now very much open for question
whether the
bank of england think the economy is
strong enough to take that level of
interest interest rate increases
um which is what the forecast is
conditioned upon is now very much open
to question the other thing of course is
that the bank of england is assuming a
40 increase in energy bills on top of
what households are already paying and
yet assuming that the government stands
by and does nothing i don't think that's
realistic in the fourth quarter of the
year i think the government would have
to respond if that price increase came
through so there are some levers i guess
you're saying that the government could
could pull potentially but but if we're
talking just about what the bank of
england can do uh and should do
yes the prospect of lower growth of
course is a bad thing but high inflation
can be self-fulfilling and can make the
outlook for growth even worse and when
you are forecasting now double-digit
inflation over 10 inflation
this increase increase in interest rates
from 0.75
to 1
is is relatively small even if as those
questions from ed conway uh rightly
suggested that this is going to be
an increase in interest rates that will
hurt people
look it will hurt people and i think
andrew bailey was at pains and he's
going to be at pains for some months to
come to say this is not something
he or any other policymaker feel
comfortable about because what has
happened is there's a huge energy price
shock that is pushing
inflation up to north of 10
that the uk policy makers be there the
treasury be the bank of england
are fairly limited in what they can do
to respond to that and households have
got to take unfortunately a lot of the
pain which in the in and of itself will
start to bring inflation down the
delicate calculation the bank of england
have got to make in the governor andrew
bailey is the degree to which that is
self-correcting and get inflation down
to two percent or whether and you're
absolutely right in your question
whether a ten percent inflation will
start to have what is known as second
order effects
wages other prices start to go up far
more than two percent on a sustained
basis and therefore you know starts to
squeeze costs of living not just through
the energy group but through all
products that households and businesses
buy
and then and then just quickly um simon
clearly those forecasts we've been
touching on particularly from the second
half of this year and next year from the
bank of england are pretty gloomy in
terms of outlook what about the effect
of what they've done today they've
increased interest rates by 25 basis
points to 1
does that hit consumers immediately
does it have a an immediate effect or
does it take a bit of time and is is the
effect relatively relatively small in in
the short term well this is the silver
lining actually if you like to what is a
difficult message for the bank of
england 80 of mortgage debt in the uk
about 1.4 trillion pounds worth is
actually on fixed rates so those don't
change those lenders can't change that
overnight what they over the course the
next two three years those will start to
go but that is very much pain deferred
we also must lose sight very quickly on
the fact that savers long suffering
savers for more than 12 13 years facing
very low interest rates now get a bit of
a boost and they'll be all eyes on banks
to see if they pass through that extra
25 basis points to savings accounts
so i'm a french from pameo gordon thanks
so much uh for joining us on that news
that the bank of england's hiked rates
to one percent and lowered their
forecasts quite significantly of the
outlook for growth in the uk economy in
the next year or two the british pound
is down nearly two percent against the
us dollar in light of that we're going
to much more analysis of this and for
mark austin on the ground in ukraine on
sky news
[Music]
[Music]
you